flying insects are some of the most
agile maneuverable creatures on earth
able to fly in any direction almost
instantaneously their aerial agility
allows them to avoid predators and land
on moving objects with precision
airplanes and helicopters embodies some
of the maneuverability of flies but
miniaturizing these machines to the size
of insects presents significant
technical challenges in control design
manufacturing and power delivery now a
team of scientists at Harvard University
has developed a lightweight insect scale
flying robot that mimics the form and
function of flies an engineering
achievement in the meso scale which is
too large for microscopic electronics
and too small for conventional macro
scale manufacturing and assembly
weighing in at just 80 milligrams and
with a wingspan of three centimeters
this tiny flyer receives power and
control via a tether made of lightweight
carbon fiber and thin plastics all of
its components are designed to be
mass-produced the flapping of the wings
is generated by piezoelectric muscles
which move back and forth in response to
changes in voltage the wings also rotate
forward and back like shoulders rolling
in their sockets which generates
downward thrust and enables the robot to
fly each wing flaps and rotates
independently allowing the robot to
immediately self correct its position
and orientation the wings can flap at
nearly the same frequency as flies of
comparable size approximately 120 beats
per second like an insect
this flying robot has the ability to
hover and move laterally between
discrete points in space it has
maintained upwards of 20 seconds of
stable sustained flight should robotic
flies become easily reproducible these
devices may provide a new medium for
exploring the mechanics of insect flight
as well as inspiring the development of
miniaturized power sensing and
computational technologies
you